[Música]
y
me gustaría invitarlos a que vayamos un
poquito atrás en el tiempo a un viernes
como hoy pero mi adolescencia o sea casi
la prehistoria
y eres ese viernes yo estaba invitado a
una fiesta y como era un romántico
empedernido y lo sigo siendo estaba
convencido que ese viernes iba a conocer
a la mujer de mi vida y para eso decidí
recurrir a mi arma de seducción más
infalible una camisa estampada con
flores
no me pregunten por qué es el día de hoy
que no entiendo cómo todos mis amigos y
yo en la adolescencia teníamos cada uno
una camisa estampada con flores como si
el solo uso de la prenda se lograra que
las mujeres cayeran rendidas a nuestros
pies cosa que no sucedió pero además de
la camisa de flores yo quería saber cómo
estaba cómo me veía y para eso decidí y
pasear me delante de mi madre a ver qué
me decía pase una vez nada
segunda vez nada
tercera vez la pnc haré de mama
hoy tengo esa fiesta en la que tanto te
hable
como me veo
mi mamá con absoluta policía me miró de
arriba abajo y de abajo hacia arriba me
dijo así vas a ir a bailar
no seas pajarón quien va a querer bailar
con un florero en dos patas
durante toda su vida mamá criticó todo
lo que yo hacía decía yo pensaba los
amigos que elegía estaban mal los
lugares que frecuentaba estaban mal los
libros que leía estaban mal la película
que eligiera y el cine estaba mal en mi
perfume está mamá en equipo está mal
todo lo que yo hacía estaba mal mi
nombre es andy soy el segundo de cuatro
hermanos y la verdad que no me puedo
quejar porque mis padres me dieron todo
seguridad educación mamá en término de
crítica no se guardó nada
y la verdad es que de los cuatro hijos
de la que más la resistida no podía
tolerar tanto pensamiento negativo
entonces me enfrentaba a todo el tiempo
por eso siempre digo que como ama tengo
una relación de alto impacto
tocábamos todo el tiempo
hace seis años atrás el amor de mi padre
mi madre fue cayó en un en un cuadro
severo de depresión que derivó en
alzhéimer la enfermedad que afecta a 40
millones de personas en todo el mundo se
estima que para el año 2050 esta suma
llegará a 250 millones de personas y la
probabilidad de padecer esta enfermedad
en mayores de 85 años será de una cada 2
personas
la medicina descubrió el alzhéimer hace
más de 100 años y a pesar de todos los
progresos y los y la evolución que tuvo
en un montón de áreas y de patologías
todavía no encontró una cura una
respuesta o una solución
el alzheimer no perdona
y esto no se bien porque mi abuela
falleció a los 78 años con un cuadro de
alzheimer mi suegro hace más de 12 años
que tiene la enfermedad y mamá está
internada con el samba en un instituto y
yo lo voy a visitar todas las semanas
ironías de la vida de sus cuatro hijos
el menor falleció y mi hermano mayor y
mi hermana menor emigraron a eeuu así
que soy el único en argentina para
acompañarla durante este proceso
el alzheimer arrebata de nuestros seres
queridos sus recuerdos y su memoria que
son fundamentales para toda persona es
lo que determina nuestro lugar en el
universo nuestra relación con el tiempo
y el espacio es lo que nos separa de un
ser vegetal la dulcera animal y además
de esto la enfermedad que no perdona
aniquila todas las estructuras
temporales qué significa esto
cuando la voy a visitar a mamá
ella no sabe si es viernes sábado lunes
primavera o verano
por eso nos concentramos en las cosas
simples la altura de un árbol el color
del otoño
a veces hasta me atrevo a repetir un
diálogo imaginario entre dos pajaritos
que se acercan a comer unas migajas de
pan y la verdad es todo muy divertido y
lo pasamos muy bien y a mí me demandó un
ejercicio creativo constante que me
encanta hasta que mamá en un rapto de
lucidez o quizás con un poco de
nostalgia por las buenas viejas épocas
me mira muy seria y me dice vos crees
que dos pajaritos pueden hablar no seas
pájaro
sin embargo
qué maravilla es poder vivir el instante
vivir el instante
cuantos poetas y escritores han escrito
páginas y páginas de libros sobre la
importancia de atrapar el instante de
vivir cada cada segundo cada momento de
nuestras vidas a eso nos lleva la
enfermedad que no perdona los pacientes
los haimar se concentran en el inmediato
en el los los simples
y yo que si sé lo que es planificar que
si sé lo que es una agenda y que les
podría decir a todos lo que están
exactamente cuántos días faltan para la
navidad con esta enfermedad
aprendí a valorar cada minuto que estoy
con mi madre a mi lado aunque ella
mentalmente está en cualquier otra parte
hace poco ocurrió un pequeño milagro
la fia visitar salimos a caminar me
senté en un banco de plaza y yo a mi
lado y de la nada empezó a hacerme
caricias en la espalda con la palma
abierta y como venimos de una familia
que no está hábito al contacto físico mi
primera reacción fue
porque estabas haciendo eso
y mi mamá me dijo algo que nunca pensé
que iba a escuchar en mi vida
me miró con sus ojitos y su voz un tanto
ron que me dijo andy me encanta todo lo
que haces
el alzheimer nos desafía a dar lo mejor
que tenemos los seres humanos que es el
amor absoluto e incondicional el amor
que realmente lo da todo y no espera
nada a cambio
soy padre de dos hijas y recuerdo hace
mucho tiempo cuando el cambio de los
pañales la conexión que teníamos a
través de la mirada era maravillosamente
enigmática era maravillosamente
enigmática
yo pensaba estas pequeñas personas no
saben quién soy no saben quiénes son
ellas en qué país viven qué día es y
esto me hizo pensar igual que mamá con
su cuadro alzheimer y esto me hizo
pensar yo también fui un bebé
mi mamá me alimentó me arropó me cambió
los pañales incluso se despertó un amigo
de la noche para apaciguar mi llanto y
con ese espíritu
que yo estamos espíritus los pañales que
le voy a visitar
y cuando la traen hacia mí cuando la
enfermera la cerca y ella está feliz
peinada
a mí no importa que no sepa qué día es
que no soy yo
porque como custodio de su memoria
yo sé quién es ella
como guardián de sus recuerdos
yo no me olvido ni me pienso olvidar
quién es ella
el alzheimer es implacable pero no es el
fin del mundo es apenas una etapa de la
vida como la primera infancia en la que
nuestro ser querido necesita de otro
todos los que estamos acá fuimos bebés
necesitamos de otro
esto se repite con alzheimer es una
etapa de la vida no es el fin del mundo
y además es implacable y no tiene cura y
no tiene solución pero no puede con el
amor
como conozco muchos pacientes con
alzheimer cuando ya visitar a mamá
saludo además saludó a santiago saludo
un montón de gente y me dio cuenta que
ellos perciben el amor que uno les da en
eso el alzheimer no puede
para mí el alzheimer es una oportunidad
una enfermedad que no tiene cura me
permitió curar mi relación con mamá
para mí el alzheimer es una bendición
por eso les digo no esperemos a una
enfermedad que no perdona
para abrir el corazón y perdonar
hagámoslo a tiempo hagámoslo sin
enfermedades de por medio sin rencores
sin culpas a pleno a fondo
hagámoslo ahora muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]